- C'est quelque chose qui
m'habite depuis super longtemps.
- Kim O'Bomsawin a entrepris
un projet titanesque :
tendre son micro et tourner
sa caméra vers les 11 premiers
peuples du Québec et du Labrador
pour qu'ils puissent raconter
leur histoire.
KIM O'BOMSAWIN,
réalisatrice et productrice
- On veut montrer à tout
le monde qu'on est des peuples
extrêmement riches au niveau
des langues. 11 langues, hein,
les gens oublient.
11 premiers peuples, 11 langues,
11 cultures, 11 systèmes
de valeurs, de croyance,
d'organisation sociale
et politique. Donc, c'est
vraiment ce qu'on veut mettre
en valeur avec des personnalités
fortes, engageantes.
- Un tournage de plus de
80 jours qui permettra
à des centaines d'hommes
et de femmes de toutes
générations de raconter
leur histoire à leur manière.
IVANIE AUBIN-MALO, danseuse
- Notre génération, il y a assez
de temps qui a passé pour
guérir des blessures,
pour qu'on retrouve la force,
en tant que génération,
pour aller vers l'autre.
Mais c'est important pour nous
aussi de faire des allers-
retours dans le... comme
le coeur de nos communautés,
puis vers l'extérieur pour
comme trouver la force.
- L'objectif : décoloniser
l'imaginaire collectif
des préjugés et des omissions
encore trop présents par rapport
aux Premières Nations.
FRANCINE ALLAIRE, productrice
- L'histoire est écrite par
les conquérants. Là, maintenant,
c'est une autre version,
un autre point de vue.
Et je pense, même au niveau
spirituel, que ça va beaucoup
nourrir les gens également.
Les gens sont en quête de sens,
surtout en pleine crise
climatique. Et j'espère que
cette série-là va être une clé.
- En plus de la série
documentaire, le projet sera
aussi décliné en balados,
en livres, en une exposition et
en un film pour le planétarium.
Un projet guidé par un comité
de sages, des gardiens de
la mémoire représentant
les 10 Premières Nations
et des Inuits qui peuplent
le territoire depuis
des temps ancestraux.
- Je suis tout le temps
extrêmement touchée
puis reconnaissante d'avoir
la chance de rencontrer des gens
aussi grands, plus grands que
nature, qui ont des histoires à
raconter qui datent des siècles
derniers. C'est tellement riche!
Donc, j'ai juste hâte d'en faire
profiter tout le monde.
- "Laissez-nous raconter"
sera une célébration de
la résistance, de la résilience
et de la renaissance
des premiers peuples.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
R.-C., Sainte-Anne-de-Bel